my name is Steve satanic I'm a professor
from the University of Pennsylvania and
I'm gonna be telling you today a little
bit about a project we've been working
on for the last many years called vellum
which is about verifying the LLVM and
before I get too far I want to emphasize
that this is a big collaboration with
many students and postdocs and
collaborators over the years and I
wouldn't be able to be here to tell you
about it without all these great people
so I want to thank them so what I'm
gonna tell you about today is our
ongoing work to do formal verification
of LVM code so just by a show of hands
how many people here are familiar with
LVM to some extent okay most people okay
that's actually more than I expected so
I'm gonna start with a little bit of a
review of LLVM just get us all on the
same page and then talk at a fairly high
level about how we define a formal
semantics for it in the interactive
theorem prove our clock and kind of
sketch how we use that to do some
interesting things like verify program
transformations and wind up with some
some future and related work
okay so let's jump right in so for this
audience it sounds like most of you are
familiar with the LVM compiler
infrastructure so it's this great
compilation framework that was
introduced by chris latin or a while
back and the basic idea is that the LLVM
which the low-level virtual machine
provides a sort of common intermediate
representation for compiling many many
source languages to many different
target platforms so the idea is it
provides a kind of common abstraction
that you can use to lower C or C++ or
Swift or Haskell or Scala etc to your
favorite architecture and for the
purposes of this talk the most important
pieces of the LLVM are its intermediate
representation this
so-called IR thus I'll say a little bit
more about what that is in a minute and
the nice thing about the LVM as a
compiler infrastructure is that it's
structured as a kind of series of
analyses and transformation passes that
work in terms of this IR so that means
that if we study this intermediate
representation or understand its
properties we can sort of use that we
use that insight throughout all the the
compiler and of course this is not to
say that there isn't lots of interesting
work going on in the front ends that
lower the code to the IR or in the back
ends which do high-performance code
generation for various architectures but
for the purposes of this work we've been
focusing on this middle piece so just as
a refresher and for those of you haven't
seen it before I'll just give a quick
overview of what an example LLVM ir
program looks like so here to the left
of the screen you'll see some sample LVM
code this is my favorite everybody's
favorite factorial function you can
write it in many different ways this one
happens to to use a kind of loop
structure and you know I don't want you
to read all the details of this code but
just get a sense of what its structure
is so this is defining a top-level
function called factorial it takes a
single 64-bit integer parameter n and
then it has a bunch of blocks basic
blocks so the LLVM
ir code is structured in terms of the
classic control flow graphs that we're
all familiar with from the compilers
class if you've taken one and so each
block in this in this control flow graph
has a label the labels are the blocks
themselves contain essentially straight
line code for writing down operations
like arithmetic and bit shifts and
comparisons and loads and stores from
memory and so on and then the blocks are
wired together by essentially go twos or
conditional branches that turn these
lots of code into a control flow graph
one interesting design choice that LLVM
makes and is also well appreciated the
compiler literature is that it uses
what's called static single assignment
so SSA which means that if you look at
each of these instructions essentially
you can think of them as an assignment
to either a local variable or register
something like this but that assignment
only appears once
so once you've introduced such a
definition for example % n1 gets some
value
you'll never overwrite that value and so
in some ways this makes the LLVM IR code
a bit more like a functional program
where you can think of these as let
introductions as opposed to just sort of
C style imperative updates and that's a
nice representation choice for doing
various kinds of analyses and
optimizations in the IR as a consequence
of doing SSA one of these sort of maybe
unfamiliar things that you will see an
LLVM code if you're used to programming
at the source level is what are called
fee nodes and these are sort of
fictional instructions that semantically
essentially assign their their left hand
side based on the dynamic behavior of
the program so the intuition is that you
have a bunch of branches and if for
example the code jumps to the start
block via the then block then the pheno
twill select out the in this case n2 as
the value that will be assigned to n1
and if you happen to come in from this
entry block which is implicitly named
zero then you'll get the value n so P
nodes sort of semantically dynamically
choose based on the where the code came
from and that's useful for maintaining
this SSA invariant the other interesting
thing about LV Mir is that it's it's
typed so you'll see all these little I
64 and I 64 star annotations sprinkled
the code and that's just lVN's notation
for 64-bit integers and pointers to
64-bit values it has a rather rich type
system that all I'll talk about in a
minute so that's just kind of a
top-level tour of what LVM code looks
like but if you dig a bit deeper as I
said LLVM supports many other features
so has essentially a c style type system
so you can define structs arrays
integers of varying bit widths there's
not really any constraint on the size
you could have a 17 bit integer if you
decide to pointers vectors and so on the
type system is a bit like C so LLVM was
originally intended as a C intermediate
language and so it sort of inherits a
lot of the features from C so it's
trucks are more there to define layout
padding and alignment in memory than
sort of high level abstractions and you
know it has many other features that
it's acquired over the years for example
you have primitives for dealing with
relaxed memory and concurrency you can
define volatile variables and things
like that and then it has a rich system
of what are called intrinsic switch are
essentially kind of compiler extensions
that aren't part of the language
definition itself but allow you to give
well-defined calls to things like malloc
for particular compilers and then the
the nice thing about all this is that
since this is a kind of common IR
they're able the compiler infrastructure
defines many transformations and
analyses for alias analysis and various
kinds of optimizations and so on in
terms of these this abstraction and all
in all that makes
LVM a rather pleasant target for
compiling high-level languages so you
can easily you know omit LLVM code and
benefit from all of the optimizations
that it's able to provide
ok so that's great
but it's a little bit complicated and it
has gotten more complicated over the
years so I started working
LLVM semantics back in LVM version 2.6
which is way in the depths of history
and LVM has been evolving over time so
these days if you take a look at the
LLVM reference manual and i only had
time for the table of contents you'll
sort of see that it's what started out
as sort of a beautiful core language has
kind of grown over the years and you
know many of these things are intrinsic
that are there for special purpose
domain-specific languages and so on but
many of these features were added over
time to accommodate new kinds of program
transformations and optimizations and
just to kind of give you a little
glimpse of some of the what I'll call
semantic complexity of LVM I'll take one
example which is about undeath so one
interesting consequence of the fact that
LV Mir is this intermediate language
it's not a source language is not a
target language so it's intending to
abstract over the details of many
possible target architectures so in some
ways it's providing a language that has
much under specification in its
behaviors and in order to account
basically to allow for you to compile it
to various different target platforms
without committing to too much you know
too many specifics and one aspect of
that is something called undef which is
there in the LLVM it's in some ways if
you were to add this to a source
language you should think of this as an
volatile register or every time you
mention it it is a kind of under bateria
but undefined or indeterminate bit
pattern and undef scum in any type at
all so you can have an undefined 64-bit
value and undefined pointer etc and
semantically you know in the sort of
description of undeath it's used for you
know describing what happens if you read
from an uninitialized piece of memory or
you load from volta memory or some of
the operations are under specified
depending on the platform like not all
platforms treat
it shift operations in the same way and
so on okay so undef is there and they
included it's used internally to give
the compiler flexibility when doing
program optimizations and just to kind
of give you a little sense of some of
the complexity of the semantics that
this introduces you might ask yourself
okay what is the value of the variable Y
after you run the following little
snippet of code so here I'm saying that
X is whatever you get for oaring the
undef which is a 8-bit integer in this
case so think of a byte with a constant
one and then taking Y to be whatever you
get by X or an X with itself okay so any
suggestions about what Y should be after
this operation yeah false well it should
be a zero that might be one plausible
answer but actually because of the undef
semantics you can actually choose many
different possible values for Y and it's
because of the kind of optimizations
that LVM would allow so just to give you
a sense of that intuitively since
undeath means an arbitrary but
unspecified bit pattern in this case
eight bits we could think of the i8
undef as being some arbitrary element of
the set 0 to 255 right it's a byte the
constant one is just the constant one
there's only one such value so that's
good
but this means if we were to sort of
step through what happens when we
evaluate X well we're taking X as
undeath or 1 so if you think about it
that's going to set the low bit of
whatever value we happen to have to one
so that means that X will be the set of
all possible odd bytes so 1 3 5 etc and
now if we were to X or Y with X kind of
point wise so we could arbitrarily
choose any possible value for x and
do it again well zero is an allowed
value and that is what most
optimizations would you know lower the
code to but actually according to LLVM
semantics you could pick any even number
because if you look at the set of odd
numbers ex-ored with themselves the only
thing you know is that the last bit is
going to be zero and so you get any even
value okay so that's that's just an
interesting quirk of the LVM and when we
started formalizing this I said to
myself that is crazy why in the world
would X XOR itself not always give you
zero and you can go back and look on the
LLVM developers list there's a lot of
discussion when they introduced this
kind of semantics and this is what is
kind of there but why does that make
reasoning about LLVM code complicated
well consider these two things so we
have x x 2 which we just saw depending
on whether X is undef or not could give
you a set of possible values and y which
is add X to itself twice which again
semantically should give you the set of
possible values so you might think that
these are the the same right normally we
think of multiplying by 2 is the same as
adding to itself but now with this undef
semantics if you go through the sort of
set theory that I just showed you well
it turns out that the Y and the first
case could be any even number for the
same reason as we saw before but the Y
in the second case in the if if X
happens to be undef well it could end up
being any number because if you take two
arbitrary bytes and add them what you
can get any other arbitrary byte so that
means that since these two sets of
values aren't the same you can't just
willy-nilly replace add by multiply by a
constant for LLVM semantics although of
course in the compiler they do a lot of
work to prove for example that X is not
on Def and in that case you could do
this kind of optimization right and that
would be important to get good
performance because you might want to
replace you know multiplications by
shifts for example and so on similar
kinds of keep all things so the upshot
is because of these weird semantics for
undef
it's a little bit counterintuitive about
what things might be allowed and what
are not
so so what's the problem well if you
look at that long list of features that
I mentioned at the beginning there are
many of them and undef is only one sort
of the tip of the iceberg in terms of
LLVM semantics there's another variant
of undeath called poison which if you're
familiar with is sort of a even stronger
version of undeath that if you touch it
it causes the program to become
undefined but even more subtly are
things like pointer to integer casts and
integer pointer casts so I mentioned
that LVM has a C style type system and
C's type system is unsafe you can always
do these kind of bad casts and yet you
need to define what it means to do a
correct optimization in the presence of
all these potentially unsafe features so
this means that it's a little bit hard
to reason about LLVM code and it leads
to various kinds of compiler bugs and
mis compilations and so on and in fact
if you go back to the LLVM bug reports I
just found this one from 2017 so fairly
last year you can see it's due to undef
there's some problem with the simplifier
which is the kind of thing that rewrites
as I'm showing and if you look in the
comments you said oh I don't think that
this is fixable under the current
undeath model what it means to
semantically model on Def unless we want
to give up on other transformations by
the way how did you find this bug to
begin with well if you look there's a
guy named John Rhaegar who has been
looking at LVM correctness via his C
Smith tool and he in this comment he
mentions that there are many many
optimization failures and so it turns
out that even in modern LVM which has
been well tested well studied you can
get mis compilation of relatively simple
programs so the compiler will emit code
that is incorrect based on you know
interactions of features like this and
one way to see that is so this study is
a little bit old but it's also performed
by John Ruger who was
comment on the previous slide but I like
this case study a lot because it kind of
points out the you know potential
failings of our compilers so he has the
C Smith who which very cleverly
generates random test cases for C source
programs and then he feeds them to a
bunch of compilers GCC LVM Intel's
compiler etcetera and this is work from
2011 PLD i and at the time LLVM of
course has changed a lot in the mean
meanwhile but at the time he found 202
bugs in LLVM 79 bugs in GCC 25 of which
were considered to be critical and you
know hundreds of bugs overall and in
fact that comment that he mentioned was
sort of the ongoing effort of applying
this see Smith tool you know even up to
2017-2018 so this you know finding bugs
is good and if you're curious about that
line of work I encourage you to go look
at that and some other recent projects
about something called alive but for the
sake of my story the upshot is that I
think LVM is a bit hard to trust and
well any compiler is a bit hard to trust
we saw there are bugs in GCC as well and
if you wanted to use it for sort of
mission-critical code what can we do
about that okay and the approach we've
been taking in our project about
verifying the o of M is formal
verification so the kind of work that
John regars group is doing is great and
in fact we should you know encourage
that but it only finds bugs it doesn't
give us new insight into how we should
change the semantics of LVM to for
example make it easier to reason about
or simplify or to make sure that we've
eliminated certain kinds of bugs so that
is that is our approach and basically
the idea is we're gonna build semantic
models of the LLVM
ir in clock how many of you are familiar
with the clock interactive fear improver
just by a show of hands fewer than LVM
with few hand waves okay so I'm not
going to assume too much knowledge of
[ __ ] but just think of it as a very rich
functional programming language
in which some of the programs you happen
to write down or also proofs about the
objects that you're defining in the
language itself and this is all part of
a project that I'm involved in called
the deep spec or deep specifications
project where the verified LVM is sort
of just a little piece of this group of
us that are all trying to apply this
kind of interactive fear improve our
methodology for various kinds of systems
programming's tasks so I'm not going to
mention all of them here but for the
purposes of this talk some of the most
related are the serta Coase project at
Yale which is looking at verifying
operating systems and the verified
software tool chain at Princeton which
is looking at how to do C code and so
velum is a little bit of this and what
do we mean by deep specifications well
they're the kind of things you can write
down in Cocke so they're very rich
mathematical and formal specifications
of complicated systems they're two sided
in the sense that because the
programming language I are like LVM can
be both a target of a compiler and the
source of you know the back end code you
need to test it from both sides to make
sure that the semantics is correct for
both of those purposes and the other key
thing is we want it to be these deep
specifications to be live in the sense
that what you're reasoning about is
actual code that runs not just a model
of the code and so this whole project
has the goal of advancing sort of the
reliability of safety of of this kind of
software and one of the big inspirations
for the velum project and this whole
deep spec project is this concert
compiler which is done by Xavi Aloha at
INRIA almost ten years ago now and where
he did exactly this so he built a fully
verified come C compiler in in Cocke in
the interactive theorem prover and so
that's sort of the arch typical example
of one of these deep specifications and
the reason why I'm so encouraged by this
line of work and why I think it's so
fascinating is
that very same see Smith paper where
John Rhaegar found all of these bugs in
LVM and GCC and so on also tried to do
the same thing to concert and they found
no bugs and this is one of my favorite
quotes in in any academic paper I had to
copy the whole things I'll let you you
read it but I'll highlight a few of the
salient bits so this basically says that
this formal verification works so they
said that the concert compiler is the
only compiler that they tested for which
C Smith cannot find any wrong code
compilation errors and they devoted six
CPU years to the task of trying to
generate random tests to break the
compiler and weren't able to and the
conclusion they wrote about you know
this is not us not in the deep spec
product and not xavi a law was that you
know the apparent unbreakable ax T of
comp sort the concert supports the
strong arguments that developing
compiler optimizations in the proof
framework where safety checks our
machine explicit and machine checked has
tangible benefits okay so I think that's
super cool too one of the really
exciting things and it's the motivation
behind all of our work in vellum okay so
we're trying to be a little bit less
ambitious than concert because we're
targeting at just the LLVM ir there's
enough complexity and semantics as we
saw with just undef that we think that
it's valuable to sort of take this core
piece of the LLVM build a [ __ ] bubble
around it in which we can give formal
semantics create tools within that
semantics for creating correctness
proofs use it to do things like extract
interpreters that we can test against
other implementations of the LVM and
then use it for interesting program
transformations like in the case that
you might want to enforce memory safety
or maybe constant time algorithms you
could try to check semantically that
those are enforced properly so what is
the velum framework and i'll try to tell
you as much as i can about it in the
next 15 minutes it's it's basically this
idea that we're going to take this LVM
I are we're going to wrap it in a little
bit of Oh camel bindings so we can
interface with the existing LVM pipeline
and then we're going to build on top of
that in Cocke the semantics so that we
could build program transformations in
Cocke automatically verify them and then
extract such program transformations
that in such a way that you can plug
them in into the existing LVM pipeline
so you'll notice that this doesn't say
guarantee no end end compilation errors
although if we applied it to every
transformation in the pipeline then that
would be great but for now we're just a
mning at a formal semantics for which we
can do at least this so how do we do
that well I mentioned already that SSA
is a little bit like functional
programming so you have these sort of
let definitions and we know semantically
a lot about functional programming so
what do we need to do in Cocke well we
need to take that as our kind of core
semantically deal with all these kind of
hard to deal with issues like undefined
values and poison and so on deal with
effects like the complicated memory
model that LLVM provides for doing
structured loads and stores of the heap
and you know dealing with the
concurrency and relaxed memory and so on
and so you know we've been making good
strides about how to model semantically
most of these features and we're in the
process of trying to figure out how to
do this in such a way that we can do
lots of good proofs about it modular lis
and so the basic idea for our LLVM
semantics is there's some kind of core
thing that you can use to describe the
behavior of an LLVM program that's
basically just defining the semantics of
these control flow graphs that I
mentioned at the beginning and then on
top of that you can layer other kinds of
behaviors whether it's complicated
memory interactions or undefined
behavior undef values and so on and then
you can kind of grow this core language
by adding things like external calls and
concurrency and so on as you as you go
and so what the
basically boils down to is well we're
using [ __ ] it's a fear improver but it's
also a functional programming language
and so we're writing at some sense an
interpreter for LVM in Kok and to do
that we can use Cox rich dependent type
systems so I'm not going to go too much
into the code but for these are snippets
from the LLVM development you can see
like any other programming language
crock provides you a way of defining
data structures like records that are
defined the blocks of code that I
mentioned or the data structures that
represent expressions and operations and
instructions and so on and this looks
more or less like any kind of standard
programming language but Kok has some
interesting limitations compared to most
programming languages that you're used
to so in particular because it's also a
proof system the code you write in coq
has to be a sort of pure total
functional language which means that
it's very hard to write well you should
not be able to write an infinite loop in
coq and so semantically we have to
figure out how to write an
interpretation function for LVM code
which gives a meaning to [ __ ] in such a
way that we can reason about it and if
you think about it of course you can
write an infinite loop in LVM so how do
we reconcile these two things how do we
write an interpreter that doesn't go
into an infinite loop and I just want to
kind of give you a little taste of this
because it's not I don't have enough
time here and it's also getting to down
in the technical weeds but the basic
idea is talk is a very rich functional
programming language we can define a
data type that we can use to represent
infinite computations so even though we
can't run an infinite computation we can
still represent it and this data
structure that I'm showing you here
called an interaction tree is basically
one way of doing that and one important
thing is that this is it sort of gives
you a parameter to kind of say what
effects
this functional program could do so it
can have I Oh FX and so on and you know
the other thing is that this represents
infinite data so just to kind of give
you a picture if we think of a
computation as a tree what could that
mean well it might go along doing some
sort of internal steps that are not
interesting from the outside world like
think of addition operations that are
sort of internal to the computation and
then it might have an event say a load
from the external memory or an external
function call this sort of thing
that becomes visible as these I'm
writing shown as green boxes and then
for each possible response to that event
we need to say how our code handles it
and so we'll end up with this sort of
branching tree structure where each of
these K's says what is the continuation
of the code in the case that say it
returned an A maybe it goes on for a
while and then returns the value 42 or
maybe it goes on for a while and then
does some other memory operation and
then those terminate in various ways
maybe it fails by you know doing a
division by zero or something like that
or maybe it goes into an infinite loop
never never terminating semantically but
we can represent that infinite string of
towels finitely and reason about it or
maybe it keeps interacting with the the
rest of the world forever and what we
can do with that data structure is
specialize it to LLVM so this is again
another bit of croc code but the
important thing is you can see you know
it looks a little bit like the
instructions that you might see in LVM
so a loca load store these are various
LVM primitives that we treat as
interactions with the memory model and
this i/o type says what the interface
should be and each of these little
pieces of interface says what are the
output to the environment - what are the
inputs so the long story short is given
such a complicated data type or this
data type we can write an interpreter
and again here's a piece of cop code
that shows you are sort of step function
for this Terp retur interpreter
takes us LVM state and gives you back
one of these traces we call them of
interactions with the outside world as
its return type so this if you're
familiar with functional programming is
a sort of a monadic style interpreter
where we've picked a particularly nice
monad for representing computation okay
so the cool thing about this is you can
then extract this interpreter and run it
so I'm going to quickly show you a demo
of that it's not a very exciting demo
because it's just running a piece of
code but for example if we take that
factorial function that I had on the
first slide so here's the dot ll file
that contains that code well when we
extract the executable we can take our
[ __ ] code extracted Oh camel compile it
as an interpreter and then run our
interpreter on this particular thing
which you'll see it's calling factorial
of 5 and we get 120 which is what you
would expect so cool we can we can use
this to write an LVM interpreter but we
can do more right so what can we do with
that well we can find bugs in the
existing LVM interpreters by comparing
them or we also need to know that what
our semantics is is that agrees with
other LLVM semantics so that's a hard
problem now we can use tools like quick
chick which is an automatic test
generation facility to try to find bugs
in our interpreter or LLVM semantics
this way and for the the most important
thing is we can try to use the semantics
to validate program transformations by
proving them correct in Cocke and
eventually maybe we could do a fully
verified compiler so again I don't have
a lot of time to go into like what it is
like to prove things in Cocke but here's
a little example of a proof this is I
picked this one because it's small and
it fits on the slide it's not very
interesting it's just saying something
about renaming the identifiers in your
program it says if you consistently
rename all the identifiers in an integer
operation and then you could have done
that before after you've taken the step
of computation so it's kind of a
fundamental renaming lemma
the word alpha conversion means
something to you then this is a proof of
that fact for a bit of our language but
the main point is that just like you can
define functions in Cocke you can define
lemmas and you can interactively work
with a clock infrastructure to prove
those lemmas about the program and we've
done that for many different kinds of
optimizations soft bound as what got us
into this originally we were looking at
doing memory safety some of the
interesting optimization passes of LVM
revolve around memory register promotion
which is called the mem to reg pass and
there are various analyses that you can
prove correct with this kind of this
kind of technique so I want to just
briefly sketch what that looks like at a
high level and I'm running out of time
but so for this mem to reg optimization
pass this is a register promotion pass
in the compiler it basically takes
programs without SSA form or sort of an
a trivial SSA form and introduces those
fee notes that I mentioned at the
beginning and that's very important for
getting good performance because it
enables register allocation and sort of
many downstream optimizations and just
to give you a flavor of what it looks
like here's a little bit of C code here
is sort of a little LLVM snippet that
you'll notice uses some loads and stores
to memory to model the c variable X
because that's what you would do but an
efficient version of this doesn't need
to put X in memory it can put it in a
register that's basically the
optimization that's going on and so
mentor edge takes that those loads and
stores etc and removes them by
introducing temporary registers in the
appropriate places and so this is a
fairly complicated algorithm and we're
able to prove a variant of it correct by
sort of breaking it down into a whole
pipeline of optimizations that these
acronyms here stand for things like dead
store elimination and there's sort of
the fundamental building blocks for
doing interesting optimizations of LVM
code and the point is that with a little
bit of work we can express in Cocke
these aliasing properties can prove each
of these little orange bubbles correct
for example to use various lemmas about
dead instruction elimination and so on
and then connect it all together to get
a theorem that you can write down
formally in coq but I've transliterated
here as you know this reg register
allocation algorithm preserves the
semantics of the source program okay and
then we can extract that implementation
so we had an implementation of this
algorithm and coq we can extract it plug
it into the LLVM compiler and run it
against real C code because it's just
another LVM pass like any other and we
can even then compare the result against
the other mem the existing mem - reg so
by doing this we don't lose any
performance because it's essentially the
same algorithm we've just verified it
and now we know that there are no bugs
and and we're confident that this is
correct we can there's a interesting
stories about differences between the
sort of existing LLVM infrastructure and
our version that I'm happy to take
offline ok so that's that's all great
what about some caveats this is there's
no free lunch right so verification of
this kind is very labor-intensive and I
would say we still don't have a good you
know handle on dealing with verification
at this scale the performance of the
resulting code as we just saw in that
little graph might be the same but the
performance of the compiler itself
because we're building it in Cocke and
extracting it is not as good as the c++
LVM implementations so that's problem
and one issue with formalization of any
kind is your sort of pinned to a
particular semantics and the LLVM is a
changing target so what have we done
about that well for this first thing I
think there's a lot of progress being
made in this deep spec project and
elsewhere about how to do proof
engineering I haven't talked about
automation and tactics and various
libraries and so on that you can use to
make all this more palatable for
performance well that's
open challenge I think you could use the
unverified version of things if you want
to just test and debug and then plug in
the expensive compiler pass that you
know is correct from the final release
or there are other technical approaches
like translation validation that try to
get the best of both worlds
and for this LVM moving target thing
well this is one of the things we
struggle with there's a-there adding
features to LVM all the time and we
can't really keep up so what are we
doing well we've been re-engineering the
velum project sort of from scratch
starting a couple of years ago as this
this deep spec project and to do that
we've introduced a bunch of libraries
that we hope can be useful in other
contexts for doing with that and we're
experimenting with better automation to
make all this work better ok so I just
want to wrap up quickly by pointing you
to I mentioned already John riggers work
but there's a lot of other work in the
space of LLVM semantics and I've had a
lot of collaborations with some of the
people on the slides and you can take a
look at other interesting projects in
this area similarly I mentioned comp
search but there are also other tools
like the verified software tool chain
and if you're curious for those of you
who are still trying to or potentially
interested in getting into into caulk
itself I recommend my colleague Benjamin
Pierce's software foundation's textbook
which is a free online introduction to
caulk and you can there are four volumes
now that you can go up to interesting
data structures and once you've done
those you can take a look at Adams
Apollo's certified programming with
dependent types and if you're interested
more about deep spec or the velum
project you can find the vellum
development on our github account and
it's also linked to from the broader
deep spec or web pages where you can
read about all these other fascinating
projects that are applying caulk to
systems code so thank you
you